tous
et nous
non
donc je suis peiné là moi je vais vous
parler de mon premier projet en fait
tout commence ce dimanche après midi
chez nous aurons canapé avec mon frère
je checke m'éveille nonchalamment et là
je vois passer un maigre recherche
volontaires pour tedx paris université
alors tu te dis que j'en ai jamais
entendu parler on est en 2010 mais
montrer un petit les 6 et des courses
américaines tu devrais agressé pas
intéressant et c'est comme ça que je me
suis retrouvé à organiser le deuxième
tedx en france en 2010 ont été
dispersées qui a été vraiment pour moi
une révélation parce que je suis arrivé
dans ce monde
j'entends parler de twitter on tombe on
me dit on a entraînement topic c'est
incroyable je ne sais pas du tout ce que
ça veut dire brésil plein de choses et
les speakers incroyable qui vous font
dire mais mon dieu mais qu'est ce que je
fais de mes journées alors qu'il ya des
gens qui sont en train de révolutionner
la peine et pour moi voilà c'était un
premier un premier déclic sur ce projet
faire des choses de brit est disparue
est échue devenu fan de twitter et
quelques quelques années plus tard je me
retrouve que je vais en cours le matin
jeux dans le métro et la joie tout
l'espace et de loïc le meur alors loïc
le meur je vous dis qu'il sait c'est
pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas c'est
un entrepreneur français qui vit à san
francisco et qui a notamment créé a
organisé la conférence le web qui était
la plus grosse concurrence de teck
en europe seul loïc le meur l'homme aux
deux cent mille couleurs
tweet à je suis avec des étudiants à san
francisco c'est vraiment génial
moi je suis là il est 8h jeu en compte
dans le métro je sais pourquoi je
réponds je suis jalouse vraiment du
talent
mais grosse surprise il m'aurait bon et
rim dit est ce que tu peux regagner
confiance avec moi je sais que je saute
sur l'occasion je dis bien sûr loïc on
organise une conférence nous sommes
meilleurs amis désormais et voilà donc
c'est comme ça que je me suis retrouvé
en résine concurrence ajusté avec 300
personnes et est en fait ce que je
savais pas c'est dans la salle il y
avait un chasseur de têtes et en sorte
qu'on agisse et quelques mois plus tard
je reçois un message sur linkedin donc
première leçon fignoler vos profils
linkedin pour me dire voilà pénélope
il ya une start up qui empruntent pour
un carton sur kickstarter donc la
plateforme de crowdfunding ils ont tous
la levée d'un million de dollars il
cherche quelqu'un est ce que ça pourrait
être
et c'est comme ça que je suis rentré
dans la start-up guy marrot j'étais la
première employés dont je suis
aujourd'hui la directrice marketing chez
ims devront alors quelque chose par un
peu plus c'est ce qui a été décrit on
fait un petit boîtier qui permet de
créer son propre cloud son propre
dropbox mais à la maison et donc je me
retrouve chez l'humain alors là c'est
génial j'ai vraiment un métier
passionnant dans une start up c'est
vraiment une expérience un prêt parce
qu'on peut et plein plein de choses ont
la voix qui grossit quand je suis arrivé
on était trois aujourd'hui on est 30
donc c'est vraiment quelque chose que je
vous recommande un moment dans ma
carrière de craie ou de rejoindre un
starter bref je m'égare je suis depuis
un an chez hema et on réfléchit à ce
qu'on va faire pour nous être vers la
promotion de produits adobe est là
quelque chose qui s'est passé en fait
une idée vous verrez que souvent c'est
pas une idée qui vient comme ça en fait
c'est un vaisseau de plein de petits
signaux avec beaucoup prennent sens on
une idée et moelleux france les signes
y en avait plusieurs à l'époque il y
avait je venais de paquets sur kiss kiss
bang bang la campagne d'un projet qui ça
fait le cahier de dessin animé or le
principe est génial en ce sens un cahier
de coloriage les enfants de coloris et
après avec une application leurs
desseins trendy et deviennent des
dessins animés
owen j'avais acheté ça du coup pour ma
petite nièce et à ce moment là il ya
aussi un salon ça d auzon la france au
grand palais où il y avait 15 start up
donc on avec se retrouver avec nos
startups
bref tout ça fait sens dans la tête d'un
coup et je disais et si à la place de
faire la promotion de notre produit
on se rejoignent avec nom de start up et
cie ont posé tous ensemble la promotion
des start up française pour l'ol pour
dire aux français voilà pour vos cadeaux
de noël pense aux startups françaises
apprend des choses extraordinaires mais
un choix incroyable et c'est comme ça
que le noël de la franchise qu'est né et
en fait j'ai tout de suite senti que
c'était un projet qui était née au sein
de l'imam mais qui sortait complètement
du cadre de vie m'a donc avec avec mes
collègues on sait sport va faire ça sur
le côté on va faire ça sur notre temps
libre le personnel week-end et alors
cette idée là on l'a eue le 20 novembre
2014 dont celle ci bon on va lancer
notre site le 1er décembre
donc là on dix jours parti de rien on a
récupéré pour la récupérer on a réussi à
faire rentrer dans notre collectif 46
par tonne et on a lancé notre premier
site
le premier dessin donc vraiment sans
aucune compétence en cause quoi en vente
ou de nos petites mains et est en fait
ça a été un succès énorme tout de suite
là le premier jour on a eu l'occasion de
se couche pas tant qu'on n'a pas mis
like sur facebook
heureusement quelqu'un a leaké le
millième ce qu'ils doivent faire une
année de coucher et et en fait ça a été
vraiment tout cela gros succès les
journalistes qui nous appellent en
faire partie dans le figaro 80 start up
nous ont rejoints à la fin bref une
expérience vraiment vraiment génial donc
l'année suivante ans qui vont cas ce
qu'on fait allez on recommence alors
comment découvrir le concept marche et
on a demandé aux start-up des traits
participation de 100 euros ce qui nous
permettait en fait d'avoir un petit
budget avec lequel on a embauché une
stagiaire pour nous aider et on a fait
plein de choses super chouette comme une
vidéo avec un drone dans nos bureaux
ce qui a failli décapiter la secrétaire
mais à part ça c'était une super vidéo
on a obtenu aussi le haut patronage du
ministère de l'économie et des finances
on a fait un site en anglais on a fait
une première soirée tresses la niveau
presse a commencé à prendre un peu plus
d'ampleur
parce que on a eu plusieurs radios et
notre première télé avec les télés donc
quand même 250 mille visiteurs uniques
un beau succès mais pas encore pas
encore le toute la france
on arrive à la troisième année alors je
ne peux pas tout vous dire parce que le
noël la fhf 2016 va être révélé mardi en
quatre jours mais cette année en fait
l'idée c'est d'aller encore plus loin et
de nouvelles seulement dans le monde
digital mais aussi dans le monde
physique donc on va ouvrir un pop up
store seraient chantées visé on va faire
des portes souffert d'un coup toutes les
start up à travers la france
on va avoir des animations magasin plein
de choses avec toujours cette idée
d'expérimenter d'expérimenter des choses
et il ya une deuxième chose qu'on fait
cette année il ya eu un phénomène assez
intéressant c'est vraiment moi c'est un
sujet qui me passionne donc j'en parle
énormément
et quand on est dans une start up on est
assez connecté avec le reste
startup entretien il ya plusieurs
personnes qui sont du coup en faisant la
danse initiative on voudrait faire la
même chez nous sont déjà allées du coup
droit la suite noël de la french tech un
collectif à new york en collectif dans
les pays nordiques
un collectif en espagne et du coup on a
lancé le mouvement start-ups celebrate
ce qui donne en fait tous les outils
dont que n'importe quel collet
communauté de start up à travers le
monde autour d'une célébration qui est
pas forcément noël se se mettre ensemble
et passe la promotion des start-up
locale
alors maintenant pourquoi je vous
raconte tout ça parce que je pense
vraiment laissé project de ce type où
est son sont l'avenir il ya une
entreprise qui croient vraiment c'est
trop jek jusqu'à donner 20 % de leur
temps aux employés pour faire ce qu'ils
veulent et je pense que les connaissez
tous ce que c'est google
les side project en fait c'est super
parce que déjà ça vous permet d'explorer
moment ce que vous aimez n'y a pas de
contraintes économiques afin de ségou
sur votre temps libre vous faites ce que
vous voulez et donc peut vraiment
prendre cette chose qui vous passionne
sans emploi forcément un business man -
le clan c'est la promotion des start up
mais ça peut être le surf un peu tout et
n'importe quoi la deuxième chose c'est
que vraiment c'est un bol de créativité
mois chez l'image et directrice
marketing en entreprise de 30 personnes
alors évidemment gênant marche derrière
mais je ne peux pas faire une entorse de
coire avec le vol après chèque c'est mon
projet je peux vraiment tester de
nouveaux outils et j'ai pas de comptes à
rendre ce qui permet vraiment de donner
un bol d'air et de faire
chose la troisième raison c'est ça
permet ce genre de projet ça permet de
rencontrer des gens incroyables mais
auxquelles vous n'auriez pas accès sinon
là par exemple pour notre lancement
mardi omar excellent combat voire à
celle de mer la ministre qui vient cette
année on s'est dit on va avoir des parts
donc on est vraiment sans trop savoir ce
que ça allait donner on a été toquer
chez parrot michel et augustin
on a demandé à taïg khris est en fait
quasiment tout le monde nous a dit oui
bien sûr on va être parent est en fait
voilà ces rencontres c'est incroyable ce
qu'on peut avoir quand on arrive avec un
projet dans une relation d'égal à égal
et sans être là à demander quelque chose
de commercial
la quatrième raison c'est que c'est
aussi l'occasion d'apprendre qu'un de
métier un side project pas du coup vous
allez faire un peu de tout
donc ça peut être un site internet du
design des rp bref y'a ya plein de
petits métiers auxquels vous allez
toucher et qu'il change de votre
quotidien et vous permettre justement
d'aller plus loin enfin c'est apprendre
à être efficace alors ça c'est très vert
alors on dit souvent mais mon dieu
comment tu fais tout ça et moi même je
ne sais pas trop comment je fais tout ça
je ne dors plus la nuit mais en fait
plus vous avez travaillent tous ces
projets passent à mouvoir à apprendre à
rester efficace est en fait plus vous
apprendrez à travailler bien mieux ce
sera alors moi personnellement je pense
que c'est vraiment la capacité de
concentration qui fait la différence
quand vous êtes sur une tâche n'être que
sur cette tâche là ne pas quitter
facebook neuf matches et qu'il aimait ça
semble évident mais ça ne l'est pas tant
et je pense vraiment la capacité de
concentration sur un temps prolongé ça
va être la compétence clé du 21e siècle
est là la dernière raison c'est que en
fait un projet ce genre de projet on
plante une graine et c'est pas juste un
arbre qui pousse c'est véritablement un
fort et un projet ça a pas une grosse
erreur
grands comptes s'appelle un autre projet
et moi sourit l'adjoint qu'il est noir
un chercheur bloqué ce que tu me faisais
de faire et moi j'ai toujours pensé mais
quelque chose est en fait tu vas voir
que en faisant ce projet il y aura plein
d'autres bons qui vont s'ouvrir à trois
roues alors comment commencer alors les
conseils déjà commencé petit ces outils
thanchitt or on va lancer une fusée sur
la lune ont cessé c'est pas possible
déjà parce qu'on part des friches en
sait trop bien que c'est pas trop de
temps et si c'est quelque chose d'énorme
vous allez être vous allez être vous
allez voir peur donc ça a commencé petit
pense pas quelque chose de simple et
puis vous verrez en soit même la
deuxième c'est pas raison autour de vous
parler des gens mais aussi parce que
appartement vous en reparler à deux
jambes à vous scotcher de le faire est
ce cette comptabilité c'est une des
choses qui vous fera qui vous fera tenir
enfin quelques exemples pour que notre
métier dans la peau de gens qui font des
scènes projet qu'il n'y a pas que moi
qui suis folle ce projet qu'une banale
trope 7 c'est un étudiant à science
prend en ce moment qu'il avait s'appelle
nicolas le roux y est pas du tout
développeur ayant des affaires publiques
et voilà donc il a développé un petit
site qui permet d'explorer les discours
de trump et d'hillary clinton et on n'a
pas un mot et hop on voit là où ils en
ont parlé dans leurs discours tracé en
exploitant les sous types de youtube
voilà un petit projet un deuxième
c'était un éditeur alors là c'est 2-2
investiseurs pour monter ça chaque
semaine il envoie un mail à des
centaines de start up avec deux profils
de haut en dessous c'est qu'ils ont
rencontrés qui trouvait intéressant
résultat ils rencontrent tous les plus
hauts potentiels de paris du cherche du
travail et de l'autre
j'espère tap les adore évidemment ils
font un travail super utile qui est de
ce succès des super profits les en plus
en verve à payer à personne un dernier
exemple c'est les glorieuses ça c'est
alors une pièce doctorante et l'autre
qui était le buzz donc d'aimer dit bien
remplie à côté et alternance et cela
c'est une newsletter féministe on reçoit
tous les mercredis elle c'est vraiment
génial le procès de vous inscrire et
elles ont fait un peu parler d'elle
cette semaine ce qu'elles ont appelé à
la grève les femmes lundi à 16 h 34 pour
lutter contre l'inégalité salariale
entre les hommes et un bref trois
projets trois profils complètement
différent pour montrer qu'en fait les
projets c'est vraiment quelque chose qui
va me faire grandir c'est quelque chose
qui fera une énorme différence sur votre
cv au maximum on sait que faire et en
fait ça jamais été aussi simple à faire
aujourd'hui vous avez énormément
d'outils vous pouvez faire ce que vous
voulez donc vraiment le monde et est à
vous profitez-en
merci
[Applaudissements]